thank you
it's good to be here so
um brief background about myself in
addition to what was already um
explained i was born in taiwan i came to
the us when i was 13
did my undergrad at stanford afterwards
i went to new york
uh like most uh people who are
interested in business
back then was either consulting or
investment banking or you work for
microsoft
and programming looks kind of hard and i
didn't want to be in seattle
so i remember going to new york and
working best in banking
and that took me after two years to hong
kong because china was opening up
and the soes and china were trying to go
to new york
to get access to the capital so i went
to china for the first time in 1995
i looked to shenzhen and the play was
pretty
underdeveloped it was not interesting
i'm like man it's going to take china a
long time before it gets
meaningful and after investment banking
i tried
to do growth capital private equity
investments
but that was mostly in southeast asia
taiwan
hong kong at that point in time not much
was happening in china
then the internet came about in um
with the next netscape
and and people saw this thing called
yahoo that looks kind of interesting
coming out of stanford um and then
i was still in asia at that point in
time and bunch of us got together want
to do internet startup
so during the last bubble i did two
startups
so both of them both of them were not
successful
thank god we didn't lose much money we
gave most of the money back from
investors
and i came back to the u.s thinking what
should i do next
and end up joining um best of adventure
partners and went to china
in 2005 with bessemer and that was going
to be the second phase of my career try
to apply what i learned the last bubble
to the next wave if there is the next
way and the
back in 2005 for me was that china was
going to be
big internet space um i was working at
goldman
research in hong kong for a brief summer
and the research report i did
for goldman back then was something on a
broadband
pc internet penetration rate in china
try to foresee how big the market could
be
i distinctly remember in 2005
the internet user base in china was uh
around 200 million roughly the size of
india today
i remember in 2005 when i went to china
baidu
and alibaba market cap was about 5
billion and by the was published the
company
the price went up three times during the
first day of trading everybody thought
it was a bubble
everybody thought this is crazy there's
no way companies who's very small i
remember their
uh revenue the 12 months before they
went ipo revenue was
11 million dollars u.s and it's a
company that's worth five billion
dollars
clearly something's not right
i remember in 2005 google as the most
valuable company in the world
was about 100 billion dollars u.s
in mahercap and the world had about a
billion
internet users mostly on pc mostly on
narrow band
not even broadband only korea south
korea japan
and um us had real broadband and pc
internet users
in china was was never been converting
migrating to
broadband very similar to where india is
going today
um and then uh
this this thing called yahoo
deal happened um and yahoo's value had
five billion
and uh people was like no that's crazy
um these guys just sell fake stuff on
the
internet don't even sell the stuff this
is my marketplace and people put ads on
it
to sell the stuff how could that be
worth five billion dollars um and fast
forward to today
at the end of this year the world the
world will have three billion
users mostly on mobile um
going forward pc internet penetration
was not going to increase that much
because if you look at isps and fixed on
operations around the world they're very
inefficient
compared to mobile operators so you're
more likely to see
more people using smartphone to go on
the internet
um from three billion to four billion to
five billion
most likely they will be buying cheap
smartphones
rather than an expensive samsung or
iphone
just by sharing a lot of averages
you need to have a lot of cheap phones
to power up more people
to go on the internet so this is where
someone like huawei
lenovo and interesting enough xiaomi
will have huge growth potential
because the phones will be cheap enough
a xiaomi phone that i have
um costs a hundred dollars u.s and the
spec is very similar to any of the
samsung android phone
you will find um and now they're working
on their rumors
that the phones would be as cheap as
50 bucks or 60 bucks per phone us
dollars
when you have a phone that's the two
gigahertz of
ram and allow you to be able to
have internet access in a third world
country it becomes very attractive
as a film that people will buy i
remember when i first invested in xiaomi
in 2010
in april um it was just 13
14 people uh 15 people and a very crazy
idea
they only had three full-time founders
at that point in time the rest of team
was yet to be recruited
and this year alone based on the
projections that the ceo
pronounced on his weigh ball they
probably do about
somewhere around eight to ten billion
dollar u.s
in net sales this year
five years and the company is profitable
according to the blogs that he has
posted
um and for q3 this year
they sold uh more phones in china than
iphone
and samsung and it was a pretty big news
in uh
in seoul um i think sometimes something
something was a great company people
shouldn't worry
but the speed of growth that xiaomi had
caught all the people by surprise
um in india on flipkart the number one
e-commerce website in india
and i think 10 minutes was it they sold
like
20 000 phones for a chinese brand that
no my india had heard of before
10 minutes 20 000 forms so the speed of
change
that we're seeing in emerging markets
for cheap smartphones to get on the
internet is
quite revolutionary now anything that we
have seen anywhere else
and i think the future would be
very interesting if more people get on
the internet and do stuff
in india as of now the 150 to 200
million internet users are mostly on
narrow broadband
when's the last time anybody served the
internet on narrow broadband before
that was back in 1998 what can you do
on narrow broadband narrow band pc
internet access not very much so if the
west world cannot do broadband because
it takes too much
burden on the part of the fixed line
operators through all that out
and then the 3g guys 4g guys will have a
huge advantage
and most of stuff will be happening on
mobile instead on pc going forward
and now you look at how the world
evolves
it will be very interesting to see how
some of the chinese or japanese or
korean business models
in mobile internet gets propagated not
just
in the asian countries but in emerging
markets
as well you look good for e-commerce the
biggest income
player on mobile are amazon and
alibaba and jingdong and xiaomi
and ebay of those five names three are
from china
two are from the us and not even
including rakuten
if you look at gaming most of the
popular game titles
there are couple in europe but the rest
are in japan
and in in china that's on gaming which
is the biggest
way to biggest method to monetize
traffic on mobile internet
if you look at on-demand mobile services
sure uber is worth arguably 18 billion
supposedly raising money to 30 billion
and airbnb is also great but there's
only a few
um on the amount mobile service players
that's here
um and look at and it's growing granted
and then this whole bunch in china a
company like dd
and yd which are tax taxi booking app in
china
the daily transaction volume is
somewhere between half a
million to a million a day depending
when they have subsidy or not
and worldwide for uber is roughly around
a million
so the size is very comparable so if you
have a country
like japan like korea like china
in which you cannot rely on online
advertising revenue
to monetize all the traffic you have to
figure out a way to do transactions to
facilitate transactions
or facilitate some kind of purchasing of
virtual items or physical goods or
services
not methodology that mentality not know
how to get users to pay money of their
own pocket for stuff
it becomes a very interesting if that
kind of model
and way of thinking could be exported
elsewhere
i look at a number look at the numbers
between january 2007
to uh now you look at a market cap
lost by blackberry motorola nokia
and we did this at the end of uh april
this year
is roughly about 73 billion dollars in
market cap that was lost
um if you look at the um market cap
gained by apple mostly apple
um it's roughly about 447 billion
that swing over a seven year period
is pretty impressive and xiaomi you know
supposing this rumor that there's racing
around and the valuation
clinton rumor is roughly 40 50 billion
dollars
so it is impressive for a company that's
only five years old not even five years
old
can commend that kind of rumor valuation
in the marketplace um
and they're mostly in china today i
think including the ceo less than 10
revenue come from
china today but the ratio will shift
over the next uh five years or so
and it's very interesting to see how the
world will evolve in the next five to
ten years
that's dominated by mobile devices
with all the hardware that's out there
people will be using that to do a lot of
different things that'll disrupt
traditional um offline economy
how many people in this audience have
not used uber
before interesting
it's almost half um i use uber every day
because i live in the city just from the
city to come down here two three times
um a week you have to drive after a
while
for me it's tiring because i go to china
every month so i end up just
ordering uber x to do it uber
it's not too expensive but uberx it
costs about anywhere between 50 to 70
bucks
to go from san francisco to come here so
it's uh if you look
at gas do a round trip it'll cost you
about 50 bucks anyway
so you it's the difference not that big
um
if you do it often it's you feel that
it's much
better because you can actually rest and
sleep inside uber or make phone calls
and where it's driving you have to focus
on it so i can see the value in san
francisco as well parking so hard
you can make that happen and a lot of it
is also having abundance of
um first generation immigrant
uh in this country who don't mind being
uh uber drivers
on every ten rides i have nine are by
first generation immigrants
and the quality of uber driver versus
taxi drivers are much better because
there's a rating system after every ride
you get to rate your driver
the driver rate you as a customer as
well so being get both sides to behave
better than in the taxi era and i don't
have to
give a tip because on the on the um the
tips taken care of by uber already
so it's charged into the rates so i
don't have to worry about how much to
tip it and make sure the driver is happy
the driver always gave me a bottle of
water to make sure i'm happy so that i
rate him well
so it becomes very virtual cycle that
experience is very pleasant
then give him the credit card if you
trust uber with a credit card you don't
ever have to about paying because
you click and it's done and at the end
you get the email tell you that how much
you actually the right was cost
so if you have expensive you can do that
easily the whole experience wasn't
possible
three years ago it wasn't like that and
in the rest of the world
only six seven countries have that kind
of experience
a lot of countries have not seen uber
yet
so for for companies like uber or dd
even in chinese companies they don't
have to stay in their home countries
they have to take the experience they've
learned and go to other countries
whether it invests in a local team to do
that
or do their own business you can imagine
the potential growth
is will be very interesting and that's
why it gets me excited
to invest in companies like that that
can go global
but in every category we're seeing stuff
being disrupted
i am an investor in company called wish
in san francisco
and alibaba has a similar service called
aliexpress
what both companies do is take merchants
that's on taobao and encourage them
and help them to sell overseas so
something on etsy
can cost 50 bucks but on
aliexpress or on wish you can find it
for eight dollars or five dollars
it's not branded
it looks very similar so that people
actually buy it
and initially had to wait three weeks
four weeks for it
and now both companies have cut down the
waiting time to something as
quickly as a week a week and a half and
even amazon style will cost five to
seven days to deliver
so waiting another five days for
something that's really cheap
it's not a problem for most users
especially for women users
and so we see growth for wish
and aliexpress extremely fast when i
invested in which
back in end of last year their
daily volume was about 50 000 u.s
sku was roughly about a hundred thousand
fast forward today based on numbers that
the ceo has told the press before
sku gone from 100 000
to over 30 million
for any walmart store what's the number
of sku
inside the average walmart store less
than 200 000 and a walmart is huge
can you imagine searching for 30 million
skus
so if you have a a team that's came from
google yahoo that understands search
that can figure out a way to solve this
matching problem
to take relevant skus to show to users
you don't have to search and spend time
on it
and look us through quickly and based on
your choices they figure out what else
will interest you
have an algorithm that does that it
makes it a lot simpler
for a user to pick stuff they can do a
lot of a b testing within the first two
hours
new products come up see how users react
worldwide
and then figure out how to to place
these products laid out for the rest of
the day
it's very interesting to take this
search problem to here so that user
doesn't have a searching book and just
browse
and enjoy what they get and that kind of
user experience is very interesting
and it's more possible to be developed
here but the backend of
including the merchants had to come from
china because china has the most number
of online merchants
on taobao with a company that's doing
220 billion dollars in gmb
that's more than amazon and ebay
combined there are 8
million merchants on it that our
experience is selling
even if a lot of them you could argue
maybe something fixed up or not
efficient or what have you
all the kind of excuses the top 10
percent i would argue
is still very good they can produce
stuff since stuff that's everybody
excited stuff you buy
walmart therefore the user's experience
over a period of time
will be as good as you can get from
walmart you can do it from the comfort
of your bed
of your home in your car and do it
whenever you want to so
the cost of opening up a walmart store
worldwide varies but it will be
expensive
and it will be natural limitation and
speed how fast
walmart can roll out and one was already
the most efficient retailer in the world
imagine your offline experience in china
or india
emerging markets elsewhere if you have
mobile commerce you'll be much easier to
do that
and take what could have been possible
for retail
shift to mobile and that's super
exciting for guys like us
because we want to see how big these
companies can get and be
and it's why we're in this business
so mobile commerce in for china and us
alone
is a 20 billion dollar market uh
it's a 70 billion dollar market in 2013
it was 20 billion market only about a
couple years ago
and it's just interesting to see how
that market has exploded
in the last uh two years
and we have a unique advantage because
we were investors in alibaba
back in 2003 and remain in touch with
the management team
and advise them on some of the us deals
and china deals
as they expand beyond just being an
e-commerce company
into finance and into social networking
and into uh investing in technologies
that will help them to become even
better at what they do
we're investors in house how many people
have used house
before so for the people who do have how
have a house they want to decorate uh
word remodel there's
lots of ideas you can get on it and now
you can buy stuff from house as well
and so you will see going forward more
and more companies
that only can have sharing of what's
interesting and what's cool people style
you can follow to get new ideas
at the same time one click away from
buying this stuff
most companies have noticed since i come
back to the u.s to invest in the us
have tend to use affiliate model have
stuff that's interesting
um show people and then get users to go
elsewhere to make that transactions
but that experience is broken because as
a
as a consumer who shop online you don't
want to go to
20 30 different places to buy stuff you
can buy from one place like amazon
it makes your shopping experience a lot
better so going forward
i would argue you will see more company
like house or malaysia l or wish
that you can buy stuff on the website or
on the app
the merchants the inventory is elsewhere
somebody else's
but the app or the website will be
responsible to make sure
you get the stuff delivered at the end
of day and you don't have to go
outside of the app to complete it for
people who shop online a lot
for younger users this becomes very very
attractive
so the experience of shopping on the
mobile device is increasing
yet the offline retail experience in
many countries are
not great so over time it intersects and
exceeds
and more and more people would end up
not shop
offline when i went to china 2005
i remember the smart money in the us
that e-commerce would never take off in
china
because look at what happened in the u.s
and say what made u.s
ecommerce successful was there's trust
people you can trust each other using
credit card and so forth
there's delivery there's fedex and ups
and so forth so
stuff will deliver on time within a week
and uh and there's payment
so without without any of that how can
china have e-commerce taking off
what people do not understand and i've
lived through it when i was in china
is that if the offline experience is so
bad
and you don't have stuff don't have the
sku in your city
you can wait a month for something to
come by and over time these internet
companies get better and better at what
they do
so that the waiting time go from a month
to now i mean most cities in china the
big cities
the top 300 cities you can get your
stuff delivered within 24 hours
even faster than amazon in the u.s and
all it took was eight years
so anything that would move around
taobao you live in one of the top 300
cities
and get yourself done delivered to your
house within 24 hours
and in the big cities the top 50 or so
you need to get stuff delivered within a
day you order in the morning you get it
by night already
because they will cost a lot cheaper in
china than in the us
so you actually have better service as a
result so
this kind of stuff is happening in china
i lived through it
this matter of time those practices get
spilled over
to india and other countries is going
through urbanization at a rapid rate
i know softbank after they made
investments
in audi stay with ali and then post ipo
their stake in alley is probably worth
about
100 billion dollars now and all they
have to do is sell a little bit of stock
they have the cash they can aggressively
invest in india
latin america and other countries that
have interesting investments
top ecommerce company one of them will
do well
and so we can see patterns repeated on
what happened to china
elsewhere i remember when i was living
in beijing 2011
top five indian of the indian bcs two
came through and they actually studied
our portfolio knew our portfolio inside
out
i was very impressed they asked better
questions than american vcs do
and i asked them why don't you go
through the silicon valley where
innovations are they ask people in civil
valuable what to do india
they said it's not as relevant because
china went through urbanization at such
a rapid pace
and uh there are a lot of models that
doesn't require advertising
that makes sense that would rather look
at china for example
to see how it could be replicated and of
course localized
in india which is what um the chinese
entrepreneurs did
10 years ago
and so what another thing we notice is
that in a mobile internet era
it's easy to expand from country to
country which was able to go to
um about 20 countries in a very short
period of time
because once you have good user rating
in one country
getting google play or apple app store
to allow you to go to another country is
much much easier you just have to change
the interface
and it's okay and you're still selling
the same product anyway
so having that
easy way to expect from country to
country is much better than the pc
internet era where you have constantly
have to buy
for google uh keyword search whether
it's seo sem spend more money to build
up a brand
and if the app store recommend you as
one of the product
because of a prior track record another
country is easy to get users to a new
country
and that wasn't possible before and so
the world has gone a lot flatter
in the mobile internet world and makes
it easier for global expansion as well
and wearable is a hot area where we're
definitely looking at and they're
interesting stuff coming up
apple's doing this thing and other oems
where we react accordingly
but we've seen innovations one thing
that interests me though is that
most of the wearable device that i've
seen in the u.s um
most of them cost over a hundred dollars
u.s alum costs on
129 or 149 i think that's ridiculous
even though it's high margin on those
products the addressable market people
can afford it
it's a lot smaller so it becomes more
niche more of a toy
but if you um look at the the xiaomi
playbook
if you can drive down the cost to
something that a mass market can afford
people get excited about it um people
buy it once you have a big base
you can figure out what are the outer
value add service you put on top
and you do big data analytics on top of
that it becomes a lot more interesting
as a play
because you know a lot more about users
of more users and so we become
more than just a hardware play there's
more activities you can do
how many people here have played with a
qq or or play with a
taobao website before or try wechat
okay about half so the ones
how many have used whatsapp
you look at whatsapp versus wechat which
was a better product
almost unanimous whatsapp is really good
as
a communication tool it allows you
especially in emerging countries to save
money
and do voip but the product by design
wants to be very focused very basic
doesn't have a lot of bells and whistles
if you look at wechat for people who use
it there's
tons of stuff you get your daily news on
it you
find out what are your friends think are
the most interesting articles
or stuff they read of the day you can
actually use we pay to buy stuff
um from on on on that you can use that
to buy virtual items to play games
the stuff you can do on it i i get
people
want to schedule meetings with me on
wechat so constantly people say can we
meet up today or tomorrow etc
i'm waiting for each other to have a way
to integrate that messages into my
calendar so it's easier for me to use it
but it's becoming more than just a
communication tool becomes
it's sucking up more and more of my time
everything on wechat right now i find
myself
spending one third time on wechat two
thirds time on emails
and i'm more of exception in china the
ratio is definitely the other way around
people simply eighty percent of the time
on on wechat
20 time on emails or other things and
when when the product becomes like that
it's no longer social networking anymore
there's no longer a whatsapp
becomes a becomes a way that runs your
life
and this is why alibaba is uh reactive
to that
and trying to find other ways to take
time away from from from
have users having to spend time on
wechat and
that's a lesson that most american users
or american internet
companies do not get is to keep on
talking about focus focus and focus
the product itself becomes a great tool
for one specific purpose
but it doesn't become a way to suck up a
lot of your time as you do other stuff
um facebook is great because he can do
that and in a mobile
internet era we're still looking out for
that kind of app that can do that
and in china it will be very interesting
to see how we check continue to grow
and monetize and evolve
one thing that comes that we haven't
figured out is how to do globalization
i remember distinctly they try not to
expand aggressively but focus more on um
asia specifically greater china and i
think in hindsight
i'm hoping that i realized that it's a
mistake because the kind of things they
could have done
in asia and outside of asia um they
could be bigger than
uh what's happening in emerging markets
not just in china
um and i think the next crop of chinese
entrepreneurs
if they see xiaomi do well in
globalization i think more and more
companies
will have the guts to try global markets
and become more globalized
that's why i think being first-century
immigrants in
countries like u.s and elsewhere where
you can see
a big internet com in an internet market
grow
involved but at the same time know
what's happening in another market
that may have very different lessons is
very interesting that you can look at
what's the best practices for multiple
markets
and come up with the most competitive
product on a global scale
this is not a skill set that was
valuable 10 years ago
it didn't matter that about that 10
years ago but i think for the next 10
years
it will be a very important for keep
people to focus on that
when i talk to wish the first time i
asked them five questions
in five questions were able to make a
decision to make an investment i don't
think i'm smarter than most vcs on on
sunday
but a lot of people met them didn't get
it and passed
um the final question i asked you i wish
was uh
what's selling well on your app is it
branded goods
or unbranded goods and they told me it's
unbranded goods
from that first answer alone most vc
will say this is not interesting
um because you can't sell you don't have
a brand relationship you're not selling
uh the mainstream stuff so it's not
interesting the second question i asked
them
was who's buying it which cities in
particular
is it the new york la san francisco
crowd
or is it elsewhere the answer is
elsewhere and that second
answer questions with the second answer
will also knock out a lot of ecs
because you're selling cheap stuff to
cheap people how house are interesting
in business
but the people who who turn them down do
not realize
that that's how how about grow if you go
after
in channel we call dlc users or the mass
market users anybody who knows that
start laughing if you can grab the
attention of those users who have time
may not have a lot of money but they do
are very vocal on the internet
you make them happy they will tell their
friends about it and the cost of
marketing goes down dramatically
when you have word of mouth effect
amongst a very interesting
user base that spends a lot of time on
the internet and um
that's how talk about growth who don't
have much well
don't have much money to sell stuff
from the friends they know or the
fractures they know
on onto the table website and other
users
who are themselves who can't afford
buying a lot of stuff at high price
and they're looking for stuff that's
cheap and you get more of them to do
that you have more skus on one hand you
have more users on the other the world
effect becomes taking place the
marketplace
start to flourish that's exactly what
i'm to wish as well you're selling stuff
from
from china that's really cheap to users
in louisiana
and in mississippi or florida not any of
those states are cheap
it's just that you have people who have
disposable income
they're young in in as they're growing
up and
in the offline world it's just not that
many skus you can choose from
you can buy stuff that's cool
fashionable and really cheap why not
it makes sense and once you have
marketplaces still flourish you can take
that
third question how much are you selling
beyond the us how fast can you globalize
and for a company that just started
experimenting with selling for six
months
they said sixty percent of users in the
us forty percent go overseas
and to see a company that's only six
months into it have forty percent of
users coming out of the us
that tells you that this the product
they're selling is highly scalable
on a global basis so you actually have a
chance to go address a huge market
very quickly very early on after the
first three questions
i was already sold the other two
questions was just double checking but
after the first three questions i can
figure it out i can help them because i
lived in china for eight years i know
e-commerce market really well invest in
xiaomi
i can help to recruit and suggest
candidates to run their supply
recruiting team in china to help them
and they already figure out how to sell
on a global basis six months into it and
so
it becomes very easy decision to make
that leads to the right guys
the back and that kind of thesis
that kind of methodology i think is not
particular to which
but it will be applied to a lot of
categories that have products
or services that can scale have global
need and whoever can figure out a quick
sooner can have come and grow 10x in one
year no problem
travels not a category we are excited
about
it is a um market that takes a while to
get a lot of revenue
but it's a market that you can actually
generate quite a bit of traffic early on
the thing about travel is that it's a
more or less a low
frequency purchase in china what we
learned is that you want to be in
business
as high frequency of usage on average
um taobao initially people go to top
ball once a month
over a three year period becomes twice a
month
over another three year period becomes
three times a month now
on the average users
number of visits a year is roughly 51
basically become a weekly thing
on average but for the more active users
who are younger living in uh outside of
tier one cities
the the usage office obviously sometimes
even
daily so you have high frequency of
usage you have a king
you as a company you have great
relationship with the user you know what
they're getting
i freaked out my wife freaked out three
years ago we got an email from taobao
says uh we have been with you for seven
years
as your six years as your child was born
in
20 2007 and uh we
appreciate the years you've been with us
to us as a as an active customer on
taobao
so on this particular day we want to
give you a discount on stuff you can buy
for your
for your daughter or like oh my god
these guys don't even own
inventory yeah they know exactly what my
life is like because they have so much
data about our purchasing pattern
that's amazing and they're just barely
scratching the surface
we they can invest more on big data
analytics
you guys should do a lot more to upsell
in an amazing way
this is why the company is so valuable
and today
at a 1x gmv i think the company you've
asked me in a longer run
it's cheap i've seen ari guru from 5
billion
to now close to 300 billion in literally
eight years
and that's primarily a chinese company
and the world out there
is five times the size of chinese
internet space if you if you
talk about from this point forward
figure out globalization and it's not
hard to do go after emerging markets
their values can easily
triple if not quadruple over the next 10
year period
and i guarantee you it will be a very
soft stock to buy
because there's really no competition no
one else will figure out how to do the
things they do
so it's up to them to figure out
globalization if you can do that
the market the demand is there why is
tencent scary
because on wechat how often do we check
which are they for the people who use
wechat
10 times 20
100. in theory it's stickier
than taba how i go there a day to shop
maybe two three times a day
but on wechat if you do 150 200 times
a day every you know 10 minutes or 15
minutes
that frequency of usage becomes very
very interesting
so this is why for us who guru be
investing in consumer internet space in
china
that's almost one of the first questions
we asked is
how user however the users come back
what is your retention rate
because from that you can try to project
how sticky or how valuable
this potential thing could be and you
think about address market
and how sticky it is you have a sense of
what
kind of price you want to pay on this
company and that's what we're trained to
do we've always seen it
um so that's an interesting company in
the travel space
but they want to get over a billion
dollars they're not as
many um and we think that china could be
interesting player in this game
and some of the existing listed
companies are interesting because they
have a lot of room for growth
because it's so hard to scale in travel
um how
often do you book a trip maybe three
times a year maybe five times a year the
frequency
the ones who already review can go
bigger and once we're younger
it'll take a lot more time to get there
so focus on the ones that are
already existing and we're an investor
in um
uh chunar and we're also a partner
with some of the other companies through
our portfolio investments
on travel the key stats is that last
year in 2013
97 million unique overseas visits
generated by chinese travelers roughly
by 60 million chinese
travelers who travel overseas last year
97 million times
and a year ago the same group of people
spent 120
billion dollars worldwide on the travel
and that travel mostly
is in southeast asia and hong kong today
with some to europe
and u.s but not as big yet
over the next five years that will
change as more chinese users have more
disposable income
and now you see a lot of group tours
people in big cities like new york and
la and san francisco london and so forth
over the next 10 years you'll see more
diys and you will see
a lot of younger users use the devices
they have
the chinese version of yelp the chinese
version of uber etc and be good at it
and when they go overseas they will use
the similar
app as well so it was in my mind you'll
see a lot more partnership
or competition between the chinese
interesting apps popular apps
and us apps should y'all partner with
china yap
gin ping so that there could be more
sharing going on and the content can be
translated different languages become
more useful to all those travelers
usc stuff over the next 10 years and the
previous 10
don't really matter because each country
is isolated
and over here we think we have a unique
advantage because we have investments
in both markets in the travel space in
u.s and in in china
so we have a better sense of how this
could evolve
some of the trends that we're seeing
it's um everything is everything
people are sharing everything
everything's mobile on mobile these days
a lot of stuff is connected it will
become increasingly so
more big data analytics analysis can be
done
i think the surprise we had my wife and
i have with taobao it's just the
beginning there should be more they
should get to know me better
some of us will feel worry a bit about
privacy issues
that concern mostly relies in western
europe
and in the us in china a lot of users
don't care about that don't mind that
and you will see a lot more interesting
services that come out as a result of
that kind of a mindset
environment um
like again we think that a lot of
verticals will be disrupted
by uh mobile and the areas that we're
looking at are in
transportation um starting with uber but
there are other things
um in entertainment um in fintech in
china unless soe banks
tend to have a monopoly on a lot of
things and wto hasn't
made enough of impact on that but all
the internet players
like ali like um that tencent know a lot
about our behavior
so they they also have a lot more credit
history on the merchants who sell on
their platform
and the users will buy stuff therefore
they're in a better position
to make micro loans to some of these
merchants
and users and that would be more
interesting to disrupt the way
that the traditional lending has been
done so over the last
two years for people who are familiar
with china fintech
and peer-to-peer lending has become a
huge and popular topic
in area to make investments and over
time as china's costs rise
a lot of the innovation that has done in
the us in the past productivity will be
interesting
so far we've noticed that the china
china smb small medium businesses
tend to automatically pay sas services
that can generate new business for them
rather than just improve cost structure
and um on demand mobile services another
area that we are
excited about we think a lot of services
should be done through
mobile in a way that you can't do before
you look at education example the top
tutors
are mostly in the big cities yet the
demand for tutoring services is
elsewhere as well as in the big cities
you don't have a good tutor good teacher
in your city what do you do
so you start seeing companies innovating
having a tutor broadcast
from the major cities and making sure
that in the uh
smaller cities whether there are
classrooms you can rent
and there could be projections or
something over over the internet
so that people can have a chance to
participate so instead a session being
running to 300 students a session could
be addressed into 10 000 students
it becomes very interesting and you
we're seeing innovations from
gaming where tons of tons of players are
coordinated to
play a uh mmog game taking that
technology
come over to education into completely
unrelated areas
because the technology for delivering uh
to mass users
can be applied to another category and
stuff that's very interesting
and i am you know we think that
going through download something similar
in a different way could happen
the principles could be very similar and
that's the exciting part
somewhere about livable there are a lot
of stuff that's going inside our homes
or automotives that we think are
interesting
xiaomi um has invested in a lot of
companies i think honduran as many as 20
to 30 companies
and all these companies are founded by
entrepreneur who are in the hardware
space
they can make speaker phones they can
make even
air conditioners and air purifiers
a lot of different kinds of devices out
there and a lot of these devices are not
smart
right now in china and i'm overpriced
because it takes
multiple layer of distributions to get a
product to the end user's
home if there's a way to drive the cost
down
bypassing those layer distributors and
sell on a popular platform like
xiaomi.com that already has 3 million 4
million daily unique visitors
you can actually launch new products
very quickly reach a lot of people
and show them that what we have done for
smartphone can be done in other
categories as well
then people are naturally going to be
interested to buy stuff that costs
one-fifth the cost
and have saved me if not better
performance
and um backed by a brand that's proven
in customer service
so they're launching a lot of these new
products initially under the xiaomi
brand
which we think are very exciting and
we're investing in some of those
companies
because we think that can change improve
people's life air
purifier is a good example for those who
have lived in beijing
it is miserable all my friends from
beijing
i lived there for two years my family
come to the bay area first thing you
notice obviously my god the air is so
fresh
um and you buy iq air blue air blue air
costs 500 bucks us
per machine and iqr costs a thousand
and and you when we're trying to figure
out how many you're buying a home it's
do you buy a two should we buy three
it's hard to figure out which room gets
priority over the other if
if a uh if a um air purifier only costs
150 bucks or 100 bucks
if we don't know what the final price
will be if it costs the slowest lot you
can buy multiple and not worry about it
and so the quality of life will be
better under the circumstances
and people will be interested to buy
because you don't have to go through a
lot of distributors anymore you can get
directly online
so this kind of instance and examples
are happening
in multiple categories think are very
exciting and it would be good
for the consumer as well especially in
emerging markets
so
the next area is more on the enterprise
we think that a lot of stuff that has
happened in a consumer space
will have frameworks for enterprise
space as well a lot of sharing could be
good
for enterprise and a lot of uh
data analytics can help the enterprise
to run their business better
in a way that's not possible before
software used to be so expensive
if you can do stuff on the cloud on aws
if you can do stuff
that's um that has a faster time to
market so user can play with it
and give you feedback so you can make
changes and come with a product that's
better in a shorter period of time
it has ramifications throughout the
entire enterprise
and makes it easier for enterprise to be
more efficient as well
so that kind of uh knowledge that you
gain from consumer interest space is
already spilling over
to uh to uh to enterprise so that's cost
of software or
as a services had come down dramatically
over the last five years
i think that's good for everyone
so in 2010 when i invested in xiaomi
um this was a popular
pitch that they give to um investors
there were only two who invest in
serious a only two find out about it but
in csb
there were more people involved and the
pitch to give was uh
they were the only team in china that
knew
internet um software
and hardware a lot of mobile oems
in china may be big but they don't know
internet they don't know how to
come up with a product that's minimally
minimally viable
so you can test it people give you
feedback they have fast iterations
for their os which was android kernel
based called me ui
they launched their first version within
three months of
the company starting and every week they
added patches to it
upgrade the os and they had users from
not just in china but elsewhere
who gave the feedback that this is great
this is what android should be doing
let me give you a feedback on what i
think you could do better
and a lot of people translate a chinese
os
into english and other foreign languages
because they thought it was easy to use
the people who do that are the the the
the the techies
we call the the the geeks but the most
rapid fans
who really understand technology they
can see something that's interesting and
they will
through an open environment happy to
contribute and help
i love that culture about um about the
us
and western europe especially in the us
and that kind of impact
um xiaomi how they they get started so
they start realizing that they can have
a really
very open relationship with the
developed community out there
and exchange ideas and incorporate
people's feedback into what they do
so every week a new version is upgraded
um
and even when the product was launched
they give feedback mostly complaints
initially
from people and they take that and
actually incorporate those complaints
into the next version of design and
upgrades so that people
consumers feel that they will listen
they will hurt and having that approach
is very very different than a apple
or a nokia or motorola or blackberry
when's the last time you make a
complaint to
nokia or motorola or microsoft
blackberry and have a common be
addressed and hurt
and in xiaomi they can build a culture
that actively does that and engage the
users that way
and so because they have users who are
interested
in what they're doing i remember
they running a campaign before launch
their first film
it was about history of
you know your phone so encourage users
to share how many phones they've only in
their life
what they like or didn't like about
their phones and about
570 000 people participated
in that campaign to share their
experience
in one way or the other of the phones
all the xiaomi executives
started first so they actually listed
most of the 50 films he ever had in his
life
and talk about what he liked or didn't
like about some of the phones
and when i saw that number i had gus to
invest more money
uh in a company before the phone was
launched the valuation of the company
went from
um below 100 to over 100
to at this round right before ipo one
billion
dollars in valuation before a phone was
launched but when i look at
there there are not many people already
participating in a
marketing campaign which cost them
almost zero amount of money to market
you know that there's a lot of people
paying attention to this
so if their phone is semi-decent not
even great even if they fail the first
time
they can still have a second phone and
probably still get 100
200 000 orders you can do that i'll be
extremely extremely happy
and a date of a lunch party on um august
2011. never forget this i walk into the
area in beijing called seven
um 798. artsy area
two thousand people showed up to a phone
launch party
um and when they announced that the
phone would cost
19.99 i mean b which is roughly about
310 dollars
people start clapping clapping and
within the first 34 hours
of the news 450 000
units were ordered at 19.99 310
each we're like okay that billion dollar
valuation it wasn't worth it
because uh that's a lot of money 310
bucks times the 450 000 units
we are okay um it's much more than what
i expected
um for the whole year done in 34 hours
that
i think signify that internet is very
powerful
you have one interesting product a lot
of people pay attention
one amount of effect will show you that
you can reach a lot of people
i remember for the first two months
after uh the product launch i would go
to a barber shop or small shops
to buy stuff and in one instance i was
getting a haircut
i was playing with my xiaomi phone my
brother was asking me what is that i
said it's a xiaomi phone
he said never never heard of it so he
asked around has anybody heard of xiaomi
before no one has
except this one person all the way in
the back who's the probably the most
techie most savvy
um phone guy in the um group
he said oh shout me phone it's the
hottest thing new thing right now you
can't even get it you go online and
there's a queue you have to wait for it
and suddenly within that one instant
all the other six guys said well really
why is that so hard to get
how is that different they start all
asking questions so the guy who know the
answer was very proud to
explain what he knew so within that one
minute period
you get six new users all trying to
figure out how to buy that phone
and the cost of xiaomi zero and that
happened
everywhere um in show me figure out a
way to run xiaomi
fan clubs to have these users who know
more than others
to be actively involved uh in a way show
me build product
and give feedback to you to the company
and get recognized for coming with good
suggestions
so that fan that culture is completely
different
than any horror company has ever done
folks before
and when you see that happen you can see
the ceo
of of xiaomi having four million fans on
chinese twitter
called weibo cena and tencent combined
you know that your marketing reach is
unparalleled
to any phone company has ever had if you
take that kind of
methodology and approach in other
categories
it's difficult for other people to copy
because it's a very different way
of treating your users um basically you
had the famous saying that
users are not god users are your friends
so if just friend call you for help
you're trying to figure it out as
quickly as possible
to solve that problem because he or she
is your friend so they want to get
back to the user user complain you know
ideally in 24 hours but definitely no
more than 72 hours because you don't
want to
a friend wait for you for that long so
if people have this kind of customer
service approach
and get back to users quickly it creates
a different kind of user
behavior and culture and that's why they
can do that well in china
and i've heard a lot of people telling
me that this approach is very channel
specific
that they use a very famous person in
china that's why
xiaomi grew i never think that is the
right answer
i think that if you have this kind of
approach that can work in any emerging
markets
anywhere because people always want to
be heard people always have a chance to
express an opinion
and see that coming to some kind of
fruition so if you have a company that
has
what in china called the internet way of
doing things
you are much more likely to build a big
company
quickly and if xiaomi actually break it
down to two categories
what is an internet way of doing things
on one side
if they their their goal is being so
selling product
xiaomi only has six phones since they
started only
six models over the last uh um
uh four plus years and uh and they only
started launching the phone in 2011 so
really only three
three years six models that's all they
do it can be
you know seven six seven billion dollars
of net sales a year that's amazing
and because people are smart they easily
compare products to each other
if your phone comes out with 100 models
no one has the energy to figure out how
each one is different
you go to a carrier to give you a
calling plan that's like
two different ones you're going to be
confused so the goal is to make sure
stuff is easily comparable
really cheap because you cut on the
middle already if your marketing cost is
zero
you have direct distributions to the end
user over the internet you don't have to
rely on any offline retailer and the
stuff is hard to to buy
then of course people will be flocking
to it and creating
a uh a strong following for it
so if you have fewer sku you can focus
better and make changes quicker because
you're gonna have a few sq to worry
about
it's easier on the relative skill to be
become better what you do because you're
not distracted by so many different
models on skus
and of course you can respond to much
quicker speed because you're more
you're more streamlined on the marketing
side
the goal is to be able to form
communities with users
so that you can have a direct
relationship with your users so you know
what they like what they don't like
you need to rely on retail to tell you
two months later and the word of
mouth fact is important so it's
important it's a problem early on
xiaomi is the first to have people come
out and apologize and want to make
changes
they do not want to let stuff linger on
the active engage social media and
create new content
to interact with users so that they can
get feedback from users quickly
so they have professional generated
content that leads to more
user-generated content
more feedback more comparison on
products so they are on top of things
and finally like i said before treat
your users to friends
if you can do that if you have much
better chance
to build a a very interesting company in
a mobile internet era
so with that i conclude my presentation
and look and welcome any
feedback suggestions questions on this
yeah good question for you excellent
presentation really enjoyed it i
felt like i just been through the mind
of a genius
with the methodology in the first place
okay so you just said that uh xiaomi
is modeling with a very few number of
skus and then targeted targeting the
mass market
could you please share your thoughts
around growth
revenue and more skews in the future
uh they are not of this company so he
has been very careful not to make a lot
of projections
but but in general um a new model every
year
is their goal and now they're having
they use different
processors in the back so they come up
with phones are cheaper because the
processor is a huge chunk
of the cost of goods sold so um
with more different processors they can
come up with two or three different
price foams but the goal is not to have
like 10 just two or three a year would
be already a lot
hans you talked about um selling
non-branded products
right as something that's really now
trending now especially
tier one cities i'm kind of curious
about what i mean this is the future of
marketing
because normally one of the canonical
principles in marketing is
establish a brand right so if you're
selling non-branded items
how do you do it you know outside of me
doing it virally but john weed is
obviously a well-known brand
right i think you will see uh specific
emerging markets two
areas one the uh the people who can
learn from xiaomi
who can figure out how to do stuff uh
using a similar approach
we'll figure out how to build brand in
the new era that would be a small subset
most people will leverage the brand of a
platform someone like a wish or taobao
who's building a brand by offering stuff
that's high high
price performance ratio so um for those
who cannot build a brand
selling on these fast emerging platforms
makes sense
because these are growing a much faster
rate than a walmart desk and doesn't
charge you a lot like a walmart would
so you will see bipolar kind of a thing
that's the emerging markets in the u.s
i think initially for the next uh you
know
maybe even 10 years nothing much would
change it would still be
you know brand leveraging social media
to reach out to more users the
traditional way
will continue to evolve but what people
will not notice is that the bottom of
the pyramid is growing at a much rapid
pace
first of all a great presentation thank
you so much um you know when
when the smartphone first came out was
direct that rectangle piece was a
product defining
the category right and then as far as
where wearables go
the watch is sort of the thing that is
gaining a lot of gravity and the glasses
have to cut out so much
um my question is as far as the internet
of things
you know connected smartphones carry go
what is the one or two devices that you
think will have
the highest potential to reach mass
market many like you speak a bit about
the market in china but also like in
general that's a good question
i think no one knows the exact answer
today um
most the wearable stuff you see are very
niche so i think
if i watch continue to improve just like
iphone did
in 2007 um the chinese brands will
figure out a way to react to that
and and and make it even more popular
i think iphone historically has always
been a
apple in general been a companies on the
cutting edge of innovation
and coming up with stuff that just which
is mind-boggling
and more power to apple without apple
the world be a very different place
and but to drive smartphones to
um the bottom of the pyramid you had to
have android to come along
to help to do that so i think um um
in in the next five years for sure there
will be other wearable
and stuff you find at home a lot of home
appliances that will get disrupted
and changed i can't say which one would
be first but i think that
you will see a lot in the next uh
five years and i think china will play a
huge part
on making that happen
i have a very broad question i wonder if
you can share your opinion
of the behavior attitude of silicon
valley venture capitalists
towards mobile internet companies in
china particularly
small ones the new ones um i think
the attitude is changing more i remember
10 years ago
most people regard china as a new song
nuance something interesting
but kind of hairy most people most
entrepreneurs never experience
vibrations relatively high for people's
inexperience
that attitude is changing and i think
when you see when people see
alibaba start investing here and the
size of the market cap
people start to ask a lot more questions
on how to tap into that
both for defensive reasons and offensive
reasons so i think attitude is changing
um by the end of the day if you haven't
lived through it it is
uh it takes a while to get used to it
does that answer your question okay
hi um so one thing that uh i think was
really interesting about your talk was
your interest in in india and kind of
how
um india is kind of what's next um and i
think it's it's interesting to kind of
take this attitude of find the alibaba
of india or find the tencent of india
but i mean what are your thoughts about
how um internet
economies in india will be different in
terms of the development from
from how things were in china i think of
course we'll be different because each
country is different
some of the business models would be
similar but it will be applied
differently for sure
flipkart as the model you're going to
argue is very similar to
amazon more of a b2c structure but they
probably will at some point
open up do modern marketplace model as
well so it will all evolve based on the
uh the um the intelligence and the drive
of this particular entrepreneur i
remember 10 years ago everybody think
that hey whatever's in the us
copy china and you're done but over the
last 10 years they proved that there's a
lot of localization
local innovations that china had that
was different from the
the us at the same be happening in india
but even in china alone
offline retail is roughly 90 of total
retail
e-commerce is roughly 10 it is roughly
about
four percent three percent in japan in
the us roughly about eight percent
um in china i think over the next 10
years
just china not anywhere else that number
can go from 10
to high as high as 50
if not more so even in china alone
you'll see a lot of disruption
even just moving from offline to online
because online just
more much more efficient at what it does
and it would dramatically change
um that part of china i think a lot of
people read negative press about china
um that's the though china that people
know about the one that's growing
slowing down to either five percent or
seven percent depending on whose
stuff you read you see that people are
moving money
elsewhere offshore that real estate
market is kind of in a limbo
that's the that's one china but the
other china
the one that's rapidly changing because
of online because of internet it's the
stuff that people don't read about as
often
and that will have a huge impact on this
china in the next 10 years
do you think that with the growth of
china over the next couple of decades
that they're
um that their uh approach towards uh
brand value and ip and uh some of these
other software
uh issues are going to change going to
continue to evolve become more western
like i guess
i don't know you guys will be exactly
western because any other day
um ip today is now the issue of
you know did you clone someone ip is
more of the issue hey i have it
you don't have it if you become big i'm
going to use it as a weapon against you
so it is it is something that i think it
will evolve
and i think xiaomi and other players in
china are actively
um building their own ip portfolio
because then
if it's a battle you can stop the trade
then it can protect you
as well so internationally too
so i think the companies will evolve
because you want to go after global
market at some point
you will come up with uh with a
different rule of law and
you have to figure out where to deal
with that and xiaomi has people from you
know enjoy joining them
so they're definitely aware of what
needs to be done
what we recommend for u.s startups like
the hardware space that wants to enter
the china market
should they find a chinese partner or
should they uh
go through like online distributors like
taobao and stuff
i highly recommend the second method
or taobao or xiaomi
because the you can reach a lot more
users quickly
um you know if you can get apple to
sponsor you that's always
you you pay the arm and leg to apple let
you get in the apple store of course
that will help
uh any day is still having a an
impressive product that people will care
about um
that then the channel issue becomes less
less of a
a problem um having good supplier
incentive to work with driver custom
obviously is very important because
without cost
cost has to be a component of how the
value is perceived
thanks for your fascinating presentation
so uh
you you said that the uh the chinese
company how about xiaomi i mean
facility it's going for global not only
chinese market but also in the u.s for
others
but it seems to me that the i might be
wrong but uh since
still this is in in china something like
a domestic market
because domestic market
which is a xiaomi motor and it's this
kind of model
is universal so you can so charming when
they enter in the u.s market would say
then they can use the same kind of
result or maybe
you need to you know figure out can
different strategic internationally i
think that's a very very question and
then we
get that question a lot and those are
fair questions um
the way i think about them is that um
the last ten years uh chinese internet
company trying to figure
figure out what is the internet and what
does it mean to build an internet
business
and right now i would argue the chinese
internet market
is probably the most cutthroat most
competitive market in the world
the kind of tactics that people complain
about chinese company versus american
companies
i think terms companies can see each
other is it's
on the border and being nasty i've seen
companies that
send on people as fake employees to join
other companies
to understand what the other company is
doing i i've seen
companies that actively fake shop
a competitor's website and then return
all the products to them
the the kind of tactics that they will
go the the company would do
uh against each other and i think
they're much nicer for u.s companies
they're worried the backlash
um so when you have that kind of uh
competitive landscape
and the market is has now what's 500
million
smartphone um phones now over the next
three year period
you can easily you know double
if um you have lower cost phones um
pretty soon becomes a replacement market
so you have to go abroad because it's a
replacement market
it's a market that arms you to be the
the leanest uh
hopefully not the meanest but it makes
you to be very efficient
so that you have a capability to go
outside so
i think what determines how far chinese
companies go will be how fast they can
globalize
i was trying to be helpful to xiaomi and
and they were able to recruit hugo bera
from android to join them
and very recently he'll go hire someone
else from android
india to join xiaomi to run india i'd
like to see
more silicon valley talent especially
those that
are more globally minded to try
different companies
because i think that um it will make the
world much better
a place when um different ideas
and value system are shared and
discussed when a company is more global
it is going to be more careful of how he
behaves
than a company that's focused just on
the domestic market so
i think in general um whether you're
looking from the angle of democracy
or angle of being more progressive um
more respectful of law the ip it's good
for china something to go global
it will have more positive impact and i
think that
as as confident as chinese as as a
country
i think over time the chinese government
has already realized that the best
company can global
from china is not a state-owned
enterprise it's this internet guys
and it would be good for chinese
government to respect internet
more going forward as well so overall i
think it's a positive thing
for both the country and the company
yeah
and i i don't think i should pay to to
china i see korean companies
be more aggressive i think the success
of line
changed a lot of mindset of korean
entrepreneurs to want to go more global
and i hope that it will have the same
impact on the japanese companies as well
because i think just good
to be more global and see more be on
your own country
one final question over there um i think
the states have
leveraged the openness to immigrants and
to smart immigrants to come and they
attract
a lot of immigration in silicon valley
particularly
how is china open to immigrant labor
into it and i i just want to know what
it is because the state has
that level right then they can actually
use it
pretty well and we've seen it here with
a bunch of immigrants here
i think immigration laws aside
if anybody has a choice to decide where
to live
and purely somewhere where to live i
don't think u.s has to worry about
anything anytime soon
um but having said that the amount of
growth i mean if your if you had joined
alibaba back in 2005
versus joining google in 2005 one
company grew
you know four x valuation the other one
the one the other one grew like you know
uh 60 it is mind boggling
uh the difference so uh you we
we we i hope there will be more of
transfusion of different talent across
countries
because it would be just good for
everyone um when that happens
for the individual as well the ecosystem
right now it's not that hard for someone
like i carry a u.s passport it's not
hard for me to work in china
i just i have to want to do it and go
through the process getting the
work visa and and a in a resident visa
it's more time consuming than it is here
but it's uh it's fine so from a
last rule standpoint that's not an issue
whether people want to live in china
especially beijing as a super matter